jules joins me now as does singer
songwriter zalon thompson who was one of
amy's backing
singers uh welcome to you both jules
first of all
um i think i saw her on your program a
few times actually
what what was it about amy winehouse
that was so compelling
i think there was a number of things
that were really special about her and
unique
she was an amazing singer uh i mean
i was her friend and we like the same
sort of music i can't speak for her now
sadly but um but i i think the thing
that was really remarkable was
first of all her voice she had a voice
like somebody like edith piaf
or sarah vaughan or some of the great
people she liked
sort of voice it doesn't come along just
every once every sort of five or ten
years but
it comes along just every 50 years
really and i think
the other thing that's important to
remember she was an amazing poet
uh you know her song love is a losing
game
sounds very simple but it's such a great
poem that i think in oxford
at the university they sort of inducted
her and brought her into some special
thing because it was considered to be
such great poetry
so i think it's important to remember
that she was really
sort of a great poet and uh and a very
good humored person you know she wasn't
uh she was she was a great
fan to be around and jules her range i
mean soul
blues jazz it was almost as if she could
sing anything
i think the great singers are like that
and i think also she doesn't have
any divisions in her mind about what
sort of music you know
as long as it's great music and it comes
from here
then it you know she loved it we did
songs that were like from old jazz
standards
we did uh toots and the may tell song
with her once and in fact we learned it
up
we were just about to do it on the show
she said but that's not the person i'm
in
oh no she said it doesn't matter we'll
do it anyway she was very
kind of great ideas and and uh and
and musically kind of very broad-minded
and introduced i think a lot of young
people so a lot of the great music that
they perhaps wouldn't
know about right and zalon i mean you
met her i understand a live music venue
in london before she was a star
just describe the moment you first heard
her sing
it was incredible i was on stage and i
was uh performing
at 10 rooms in central london
and uh i was singing to the ladies and
then this small girl comes out of
nowhere and says oh my god you're
amazing and i was like
uh thanks but i'm performing she's like
no but you are amazing and i'm like
i'm looking at the band i'm looking at
the audience and i'm like thank you but
i'm performing
and then the host patrick allen said
ladies and gentlemen mrs amy whitehouse
she sang and i was like oh my gosh you
are amazing
and we became really close from then so
it was really special
right and she liked your singing enough
she invited you onto the
back to black tour is that right
absolutely she did and um at first one
of the band called me up and said hey
you know zelena would you like to come
on tour with amy and i said no i'm not
backing singer i'm not gonna do it
and then she called me up and said baby
will you come on the road with me
and i said ah all right then it was
supposed to be six months
ended up being six years and what a
beautiful six years it was
six years and jules i mean we've got to
talk about it i suppose what was it like
watching this mesmerizing
talent succumb to this crippling life of
addiction
well i think that's a pretty sort of a
depressive thing i think that's uh
but it's in all professions you know
it's people who work in tv doctors
policemen
librarians everybody can succumb to it
so we've all got to be careful but i
think what i'd rather do is focus on
remembering all of the great bits about
her
and the most of the time i spent with
her and i think zelen also remember the
same thing is that she
was really good human she was like a
funny an enjoyable person to be around
she had a great wit
about her she wasn't like a gloomy sort
of person to be around
and i think that's probably what i
remember most about she was great
company she was like a friend that you
won't have as a friend because she was
amusing
and fun and on top of all that when she
opened
her mouth and started seeing she she
could see anything and it would make you
love the song
i think the thing about a really great
singer is it when they sing a song
that you didn't particularly like or i
haven't particularly noticed but when
they sing it
it suddenly illuminates it and you go
wow i love that song now
well and that's what he was
andrew zellon you were at the grammys
with her were you when
when she won a grammy absolutely um she
ran into my arms
and i said baby you did it and she said
no we did it
and for me it was such an amazing thing
that in her moment of all her glory she
remembered all the journeys of all the
small
clubs that we performed in front of
those people and um
and it was so beautiful you know it was
like a celebration of
all of the journey that we'd been
through and
did you know did you ever talk to her
about her sort of low
points and was that something you
discussed with her or
or was it just a sort of music
i remember i remember one point um i
went to her and i said listen amy come
come and stay at my grandparents house
we just will just get away they'll take
good care of you
um we won't tell anybody you know we'll
feed you we'll look after and she says
no it's okay baby
i'm okay and i i don't know i talked it
up to the moment that she probably
didn't want to bring
um you know the the wolves of the press
um you know to my into the world of my
grandparents because it was
nasty it was really nasty yeah jules i
mean she was a great singer great
songwriter as you say poet
um we lost her so young
27 that age again i mean what would she
have gone on
do you think to become it's interesting
to think i mean it's impossible to know
but it's interesting to think what she
would have
gone because she the one thing is if she
had been well she would have had
longevity wouldn't she
i think that of anybody she really would
i think she's like one of the great
singers that's what i mean like one of
the great singers of all time the great
and you really uh and and zaylon who's a
fantastic singer will know this
but you know there's great singers and
they're singers who are really great but
the ones that just come up
very you know every set of 25 years or
whatever and she was one of them so i
think
by now also her writing and her poetry
she would have written more grey songs
which of course we're never going to
hear but i think she would have done
more great songs
and she loved to sing so there would
have also been just little moments
that we would have had on television or
maybe you just seen her at a party
singing a song
that would have moved people she had
that ability to connect
and communicate and move people with her
voice because when she sang she had
complete belief
in what she was doing complete
conviction so it's not just the singing
you'll be able to have the
ability to sound wonderful you've got to
kind of tell the truth and you've got to
have
the right motivation and it's got to
come from the right place
and that's what it did with her so i had
actually been still here now where would
have been
some fantastic music that we would have
had but
the great thing is we have got some
there's some wonderful things
of us that uh exist both on the
television
which you can look up on youtube or on
the record so yeah um
yeah um and so on just finally we've got
20 seconds left uh how will you remember
amy uh just complete gratitude
all the things that she has done for me
she um
uh i wrote a song called you let me
breathe just saying thank you she
allowed me to feature that album she
gave me
15 minutes in the middle of a world tour
she's she uh
i signed she signed me to her label i'm
just totally just
um i feel like i could never repay her
for all she's done okay
well uh zelen thompson and jules holland
appreciate your time thank you very much
for being with us thank you
thank you very much for having us thank
you thank you
and uh to hear more of what it was like
to uh
live with and and be on stage with amy
winehouse
you can listen to this week's episode of
storycast
21 it's available on the sky news app
and via
all podcast providers